marie turgeon arj21 le promenoir qui
n'arrive plus récents puisqu'ils datent
de 1968 et je dirais que c'est un il me
semble que c'est un roman plus un livre
plutôt les plus romanesques qu'adrien ne
serait ce parce que le personnage et non
avec inventé oui et puis aussi surtout
parce que le partage et non comme la
plupart de nous passent par des
circonstances excessivement variés
adrien eux a eu certainement beaucoup de
désagréments quelques graves malheurs
dans sa vie mais enfin si ghetto même
l'empereur est tout même un homme qui
comme il le dit lui même n'a jamais
connu la faim et jusqu'à un certain
point choisi sa destinée zénon et pour
veine on est en fuite et rancart du
temps et non à que ça arrange comme il
peut se faufile à travers les
difficultés les drames et les préjugés
de son temps et il est prêt si rld
avance vaincus ils sont en plus de ce
16ème siècle ccmc après aussi gâtés
n'ont d'ailleurs à il ya dix rapports
entre les deux personnages toutes deux
sont avant tout intelligent
tous deux ont cette passion de servir et
tous deux ont une certaine ouverture
métaphysique plus engagés et non parce
que tout mais maintenant ça ne peut pas
se permettre de passer son temps à
contempler vous dire que sinon il
philosophe médecin chemise si cela mais
leurs tempéraments sont très différents
adrien est un homme évidemment
violemment des motifs c'est non et on
contraire on a l'impression d'un
tempérament presque indestructible ci ne
tuez pas cinq ans 59 ans on a
l'impression qu'il ya encore 20 de moins
50 big band me tend un piège qui s'est
en quelque sorte burcy à l'expérience de
la vie mais ce qui prouve à le rend
passionnant c'est pourquoi j'ai dit que
j'aimais et non comme un frère c'est à
quel point ce qui vit sans apprendre ce
que nous vivons en coin d'abord une vie
dans une europe coupée par un veto de
faire ce n'est pas le rideau de fer
communiste capitalise de notre époque
série bones sphère catholique protestant
ce qui vous font exactement la même
chose vous dites dans les deux camps ont
sévi d'intérêt pour
d'avery foncier à caudan contre lequel
il ne peut pas lutter c'est un homme qui
se trouve pris entre des vues police
religieuse métaphysique que
scientifiques différentes on voit ce
différend théorie ces différents
systèmes du monde grandit au contraire
se faner comme voyons toujours une
théorie prend la place d'une autre et où
tout est encore ouvert jusqu'à un
certain point
et enfin c'est un homme qui fait face à
un monde de plus en plus à son prix
jusqu'au jour où il n'y a plus qu'à s'en
retirer pour que pour ne pas s'imposer
le pire le pire dans des conditions
inédites et surtout mais pas s'imposer
des compromis mais ce qui est vrai c'est
que vous donnez dans mémoires d'hadrien
une vision du monde à mon avis plus je
suis pas clairement primé de dire plus
optimistes plus dans l'oreille mais doré
doré que dans ces zones noires
est-ce que ça correspond à une étape de
votre propre évolution je crois que cela
correspond à la fois l'histoire est à
une étape de mon évolution
denver le monde antique fait même de ces
deux mondes antiques et où et moins et
plus jeune que le monde 2 et non de ces
siècles
il a par conséquent vu un peu moins
d'horreur et un peu moins de projets dit
il ya encore la rue à -briand la
possibilité de croire qu'un grand esprit
peut pourtant non seulement quelques
années l'a fait mais pendant un temps
assez long stabiliser le monde du temps
et non je plaisante rires une pétition
te faire il dit non j'ai bien peur qu il
reçoit exactement comme du temps mais
nos et d'autre part adrien a été écrit
en 48 et dieu sait que également en 48
et des thèmes que donnait déjà
remporteraient que déjà donné dans le
pessimisme absolu mais enfin comme
toujours après une dire terminée il ya
souvenant de relèvement dans lequel on
se dit emballé
la raison la sagesse ou tous que moi
désaccord mettons raisonnable vont
peut-être triompher mon blé de s'imposer
tandis que dans le rhône white fed entre
70 65
on voyait déjà craqué beaucoup plus
crottes je me souviens d'un mou de
robert comtesse
il avait rendu compte de votre livre le
grand marais disait que à peu près ceci
c'est adrien vit à une époque où le mot
avait du mal à devenir dieu alors que
ces noms vit une époque où l'homme a du
mal à devenir homme absolument vrai
c'est merveilleusement à dire et ce dans
des choses qui me robert panthère et des
phrases moi que ça que je ne peux que je
prends dedans dans le voir un de ceux ci
que disais non je me suis gardé de faire
de la vérité une idole préférant lui
laisser son nom plus humbles
d'exactitude cette phrase qui m'importe
beaucoup oui sûrement parce que quand on
parle de vérité très souvent on parle de
théories comprend pour la vérité ou de
temps de comprendre la vérité tandis
qu'en tant par l'exactitude chez sérieux
s'est aperçu du style on va voir par
comparaison combien le votre style
évaluer combien même dans une oeuvre
pessimistes comme de celle ci combien le
style peut être coloré les riches la
viande le sang les entrailles tout ce
qui à palpiter vécu lui répugnait à
cette époque de son existence car la
bête meure la douleur comme l'homme et
lui déplaisait de digérer des agonies
depuis l'époque où il avait été égorgé
lui-même un port chez un boucher de
montpellier pour vérifier s'il y avait
tout mon coin si dense entre la
pulsation de l'artère et la systole du
coeur il avait cessé de trouver utile
d'employer des termes différents pour
désigner la bête qu'on a fait et l'homme
qu'on tue l'animal qui crèvent et
l'homme qui meurent ses préférences en
matière d'aliments avait au pain à la
bière eau bouillie garde quelque chose
de la saveur épaisse de la terre aux
aqueuse verdure aux fruits
rafraîchissant eaux souterraines et
sapide racines et ses composés n'en aime
beaucoup la nuit il aime la vie et
l'aiment parce que les gens en ont fait
oui mais les mots glanés mai